manque de stabilité dans les convictions
gouvernementales et il ya un manque de
clarté de précision dans les modalités
qui pourtant sont essentiels parce que
nous savons sur ces sujets là le diable
est dans les détails encore une fois
nous sommes favorables à la vaccination
nous préférons convaincre plutôt que
contraindre mais il n'y a pas de débat
interdit encore faut-il rentrer dans les
détails pour bien connaître les
modalités précises de chacune des
mesures gouvernementales ya une
différence fondamentale entre emmanuel
macron et valérie pécresse élue emmanuel
macron l'a encore vu malheureusement la
télévision cette semaine où il n'a parlé
que de lui même alors que les français
en dur une crise économique sociale et
sont d'autres culturel et
civilisationnel
c'est que lui semble avoir une obsession
c'est de plaire alors que elle elle a
une habitude et si je peux me permettre
qu'une passion c'est de faire et c'est
justement cette capacité à faire et à
tenir ses promesses qui est la marque de
fabrique ces deux personnalités que
finalement que que sur le fond sur le
fond ce programme bien sûr il ya de
différent sur le fond parce que toutes
les réformes structurelles le dire aussi
j'y viens et je vous remercie de me
poser la question il ya de nombreuses
réformes structurelles que ce soit sur
la libéralisation du temps de travail
sur la réforme des retraites sur la
simplification sur le nombre de
construction de places de prison sur la
lutte résolue ou pas et malheureusement
elle n'est pas suffisamment forte contre
l'islamisme qui n'ont pas été mises en
place ou insuffisamment mise en place
par le président sortant alors que du
côté de valérie pécresse dès qu'une
mission lui a été confié que ce soit
ministre des universités de nicolas
sarkozy puis ministre du budget ou
président du conseil régional d'île de
france à chaque fois que la tenue comme
ministre des universités à la tenue neuf
mois face à la rue face à l'adversité
pour mettre en oeuvre une réforme
décisive qu'est la réforme de
l'autonomie des universités lorsqu'elle
était ministre du budget en pleine crise
du subprime et des dettes souveraines
c'est depuis 1945 la seule année où les
dépenses de l'état ont baissé en valeur
et enfin comme présidente du conseil
régional d'île de france elle a innové
en créant la charte de la laïcité un
seul exemple c'est à dire plus un euro
d'argent public pour les associations
qui dépassent les bornes de la
république donc à chaque fois qu'il a eu
l'occasion de r elle a tenu sa parole
est tenu face à l'adversité honnêtement
je crois que ce n'est pas faire une
insulte au président sortant que de dire
que ça n'a jamais été le cas le
concernant avec le résultat